seit ich auf meinem kanal einen eigenen
stromgenerator gebaut habe der so lange
man kurbelt kostenlosen strom liefert
haben wir dutzende leute vorgeschlagen
einfach mit dem generator einen
elektromotor zu betreiben der dann
wiederum durch seine drehungen den
generator der feuerwehr
also eine maschine die sich selbst
antreibt ein sogenanntes perpetuum
mobile ein gerät das wenn man es einmal
in gang gesetzt hat ohne weitere zufuhr
von energie auf ewig in bewegung bleibt
menschen schon seit 1000 jahren versucht
solchen maschinen zu erfinden und das
hier sind nur ein paar bekannte werden
dass gewichtsverschiebung grad oder das
über balance raten oder mein favorit die
kapillare schüssel eine art weinglas in
dem sich eine große menge flüssigkeit
befindet mit einem schlauch unten dran
der sich einmal wiegt und wieder in sich
selbst rhein fließt die hohe masse an
wasser in der schüssel soll durch die
gravitation die geringe menge an wasser
im schlauch problemlos hochdrücken und
der kreis wiederholt sich und altes
gerät hat sich mit lustig finde wenn ich
jetzt ausbauen beim einer variante soll
es quasi nennt richter geben in dem man
eine murmel rhein wird die dann auf
einem ball rollt anlauf nimmt und durch
die spezielle biegung wieder zurück in
den trichter geschossen wird woraufhin
sich dieser prozess für immer wiederholt
allerdings sind diese ganzen apparate
natürlich physikalisch ungefähr so
möglich wie sich selbst hoch zu heben
aber warum diese maschine überhaupt
unmöglich sind mit welchem absolut
unsichtbaren trick ich dann doch zum
laufen bringen und die unwissende leute
darauf reagieren werden dazu später mehr
dieses video wird unterstützt von nvidia
und mit kommen von denen ich einen
nvidia studio pc bekommen habe mit dem
ich dieses unmögliche gerät in 3d design
die physik der murmel simulieren und
noch bevor ich baue fotorealistische
renderings erstellen werde worauf warten
wir jetzt kommt japan wo ich diese grobe
skizze von vorher nehmen und in einen
genauen bauplan umwandeln am pc direkt
da meine plattform dann mal ein trichter
je größer der wird desto weniger
probleme werde ich sagen dass die murmel
auch genau der eintrifft sondern komm
doch rein 12 mm muss ja quasi in cm dick
durch so anja und richter haben wir noch
ein bisschen runter
jetzt wurde trichter uns diese
halterungen hier aus holz fliesen geht
es auch schon eine murmelbahn
[Musik]
dann auch die murmel hier die eben oben
reinkommt anleihen 3 demonstriert und
das aller aller wichtigste für unsere pc
mobile ein wunderschönes hübsches dickes
holzpodest runter nachdem ich die
konstruktion infusion 36 die design habe
einem der vielen programme für kreative
die von den nvidia studio treibern in
meinem mipcom pc supported werden und
dadurch optimal laufen lade ich
anschließend das teil in den videos um
die wurst oder genauer in omnibus create
einer software mit der man unter anderem
realistische 3d szenen in echtzeit
zusammenstellen kann zum beleuchten
rändern und sogar simulieren der physik
unsere speed um mobiles ich ziehe
einfach per drag drop ein paar coole
vorgefertigte materialien auf mein
objekt man schon sie das ultra
realistische aus und dank meiner geforce
gtx grafikkarte sogar in echtzeit ohne
lange rinder zeiten damit meine
hoffentlich bald unendlich maschine
nicht einfach rum schrift habe ich hier
ein kostenloses tisch modell aus der
library gezogen und per drag drop ein
paar dinge drauf gestellt damit dass
nach dem echten schreibtisch aussehen
[Musik]
und jetzt können wir die physik
realistisch simulieren und dank meines
staaten pcs den er übrigens auch in der
video beschreibung finden könnt jetzt
darf sogar in echtzeit und da sieht man
eindeutig dass da wieder eine murmel
oben raus kommt mit schwung das haus
hinten und vorne nicht hin weil die
ganze kinetische energie eben an die
reibungen verloren geht und jetzt kommt
der zaubertrick der natürlich einen
überhaupt keiner ist um das zum laufen
zu bringen in dieser holzbox darunter
die ich bewusst holen designt habe
brauchen jetzt irgendwas dass diese
kugel hier unsichtbar beschleunigt und
ja das geht wirklich wenn man erst mal
vorstellen dass das hier unsere
murmelbahn ist und dass da unsere murmel
und wir drehen das ganze dann einmal so
kommen erzählt magneten darunter legen
und wenn an diesem vorbei rollt wird sie
extrem beschleunigt das problem ist dass
die kugel nur zu den magneten
hingestellt wird wenn ich dann mal
weiter flitzen will dann zieht der
magnet die natürlich auch wieder zurück
kann aber so richtig cooles machen
und schon hat man einen magneten dem man
per strom an und ausschalten hoffentlich
ja ist ja geil jetzt so aus
jetzt ist er an
aus und wieder an und wieder aus
komplett so und jetzt ist die idee dass
ich direkt auf der höhe von unserem
elektromagneten so einen kleinen sender
bau die kugel dann durchblitzt und wenn
man ihn angezogen wird und dann genau in
dem moment wo sie auf der höhe des
magneten ist der sensor die kugel
bemerkte elektromagnet ausgeht und die
kugel einfach um gegner war da sitzen
kann und auf unsichtbare weise
beschleunigt wurde zumindest hoffe ich
dass das so hinkriegt das ist alles
natürlich viel schwieriger ist als das
was ich gerade ihm erklärt habe
verbringe ich den restlichen tag damit
zu lernen wie man am steckplatz mit
einem mini computer elektronische
bauteile zusammen stöpselt und per code
am computer programmieren kann und nach
fünf stunden das glorreiche resultat
meiner arbeit
ich habe absolut unnötiges gerät gebaut
es kann
nerven ist glaub ich sollte aber blau
und das ist wunderschön
[Musik]
nachdem ich länger mit meinem kein
blaulicht rum gespielt habe als ich
zugeben möchte habe ich angefangen mit
der viel komplizierteren elektronik
unseres perpetuum mobile illusion
apparats einige freaks die immer noch an
freie energie glauben wenn das jetzt
nicht gerne hören aber wie für jede
skulptur mobile brauchen wir eine
versteckte stromquelle und dafür schalte
ich zwei kleine akku zusammen daneben
ist die schule für den elektromagneten
mit das wichtigste teil das sich gerade
mit dem akkuschrauber neuweg mit
dünnerem kupferdraht und deutlich mehr
windungen
ich hab's nicht hingekriegt auf
knopfdruck einen elektrowagen anzumachen
ich habe jetzt mal ein bisschen der
besseren spiele gebaut das hier war die
alte das hier ist die neue mit deutlich
mehr wicklungen unten im eisen mantel
turm herum und ich sage dir
elektronische rechner als gemacht so
dass ich einfach per knopfdruck hier den
magneten an macht und doch genau das
funktioniert auch so weit so gut wenn
ich mir jetzt mal den kleinen murmelbahn
prototypen raste
kann ich komplett einfach per knopfdruck
das ding einmal beschleunigen das schon
gala muss man nicht nur wieder
rechtzeitig ausschalten und dann fliegt
er durch und auch wenn der magnet jetzt
echt relativ starkes ich kann hier
einfach
hier damit einfach diese städte
schraubzwinge hochheben kann
hatte ich mir gestern haben wir zwei
bestellt die die kugel mit sicher
nochmal deutlich besser beschleunigen
werden können 12 volt braucht der
kollege die sonne haben
sowie kratzer aus meiner ist ja noch
nicht mal wie gibt es nun erstmal so
schnell sie das ding jetzt auch nicht an
meine da ist mein selbst gebauter schon
fast genauso gut
ich habe natürlich jetzt noch eigentlich
wohl schon der das ist deutlich größer
und ich werde manchmal aber auch
deutlich stärker also wirklich großen
objekt ist das ding recht ultra stark
kriegt man kaum ab ich habe das gefühl
dass er hier meine kugeln wie deutlich
schneller beschleunigt oder so
eigentlich dass man den fall dass quasi
das teil hier in unserem holzsockel drin
sein wird dann ist zum beispiel hier die
murmel ja okay die viele schon heftig
okay das ist quatsch wenn man das
richtig heim
steht man schon ordentlich speed ist ja
lustig das kann im vergleich dazu der
kleine hier
auch viel hatte ich ja auch schon als
andere aber wir sind stärker ist ja ich
denke dass offensichtlich gefällt mir
sehr gut also kugel wir uns mal einen
fall geschubst machnig geht genau der
rechten sekunde aus und die kugel nimmt
dann einfach nur die geschwindigkeit er
kratzt damit kann uns noch recht
ordentlich posten jetzt muss ich noch
regen wie die elektronen so machen das
eben nicht daneben sitzen muss mit
diesen knopf sondern dass es automatisch
mit so einem minisender geht
[Musik]
die letzten zehn stunden damit verbracht
herauszufinden wie ich kennt
metalldetektor macht und das gehabt wenn
jetzt quasi diese metallkugel reinhold
über diesen sensor dann durch die säle
die rot das ist super simpel aber genau
das ermöglicht uns eher zu den magnet
genau im richtigen moment auszuschalten
damit das ding hier weiter flitzt mal
schauen ob das alles jetzt auch zusammen
funktioniert zum testen bei euch eine
kleine test spur indem ich eine rille in
eine dünne platte teile anschließend
leute ich kupferdrähte an den
magnetfeldsensoren
[Musik]
das mache ich übrigens damit er nicht
wie vorher auf der städte sein muss
sondern damit ich ihnen direkt mit den
dünnen kabel auf den elektromagneten
kleben kann und anschließend die
holzplatte drauf kommt wenn ich jetzt
den elektromagneten ansteck und die
kugel drüber schubse dann beschleunigt
sie und bleibt natürlich dann direkt
stehen jetzt programmier ich den
microcontroller so dass er den magnet
ausstellt sobald die eisenkugel eine
bestimmte position erreicht hat so sieht
das übrigens aus wenn man den
magnetfeldsensoren pc ausliest und
tatsächlich funktioniert wie durch
zauberei bestand die kugel einfach so
aus dem nichts der trichter oben am
gerät wird übrigens schon gedruckt
dachte ich zumindest weil dabei kamen
das hier raus und das ziel überhaupt
nicht gut aus das ist einfach hier
kommen verschoben dann zweiter versucht
da kam das datei raus wohl einfach
überhaupt nicht fertig gemacht
rumprobiert mit dem anderen 3d drucker
da hab ich leider nicht diese schöne
metallisch glänzende material also hatte
ich ein omnibus create mal geschaut ob
schwarz auch cool dafür aussehen würde
und der finden nicht unbedingt thoma
jetzt einfach mattgrau das kommt den er
glaube ich noch am allernächsten sowieso
richtig hübsch geworden finde ich ist
natürlich nicht ganz so glänzend aber an
sich finde ich kommt ganz schön ran
damit bin ich zufrieden für alle anderen
teile habe ich mir so eine zeichnung
ausgedruckt ja und die teilen sich jetzt
alle durch
[Musik]
unsere wunderschöne basics fertig in
sehen nicht schön aus weil man es halt
von außen fehlte hingegen sehr hübsch
geworden das ist der sockel jetzt können
wir uns um die schienen dann nehme ich
hier für draht- glaube ich bin kein
eisendraht sondern aluminium draht damit
dass mit dem magnetismus zeug nicht
irgendwie die quere kommt und der weg
ist jetzt ja noch nicht ob lohne um die
gerade in der stichsäge ausgeschnitten
[Musik]
wunderschön mit einem ass über gehe ich
sicher dass die drähte den perfekten
abstand haben der nächste schritt ist
dass die beiden schienen teile irgendwie
aneinander zu befestigen also wirklich
ein stück vom alten rat auf einen
eisenstab dabei entsteht eine art
sprungfeder aus der ich dann keine
halbkreise abknipsen kann und die
versuche ich dann an zu löten
gar nicht deswegen versuche ich es mit
sekundenkleber was tatsächlich klappt
anschließend verpasse ich dem trichter
seine beine montiere ihn auf das podest
und mache mich an das verbauen der
schanze das ist ziemlich frickel arbeit
und muss natürlich genau gemacht werden
damit die kugel möglichst glatt läuft
so haben unsere bahn jetzt sieht das
ding eigentlich außen schon mal komplett
fertig aus so fällt sich genau mit den
simulationen und schafft das will ich
nicht
offensichtlich der ruf zu schießen dafür
bauen jetzt elektronik ein da wird ein
bisschen knifflig liegt dass man jetzt
seitlich hinkommen mal der elektromotor
an dieser sensor hier rein so jetzt
betrifft ich das mal in dieser mann mit
einer richtigen sekundenkleber darauf
ist und damit kommt elektro nationalen
so jetzt an die elektronik in hirschau
die calwer raus die damen mit einem
späteren zeitpunkt noch in
gesellschaften drin verpacken allerdings
man sich natürlich jetzt noch mal nicht
um die genaue elektronik kümmern und das
so einstellen dass sie so der moment der
wahrheit die verkabelung ist dran da ist
bringt erkennt hier den magnet ach so
dass das war früher ganz schön heiß
naja wie der papst jetzt funktioniert
ist alles die elektronik funktion sofort
so sieht das ganze aus wenn ich jetzt
ohne elektronik mal aufhört und man
sieht die kugel geht nur ungefähr bis
hierhin jetzt wolle man das ganze mal an
und steuerung funktioniert
[Musik]
und ja man sieht die qualität uns
darüber legt da sie quasi mit
stromschlägen zentimeter oder anhalt
weiter geht und das liegt auch am
magneten aber uns reicht die power hier
bei weitem nicht aus um das zu beheben
wir euch jetzt gebaut hat man das
bauteil schon bestellt allerdings muss
ich dafür jetzt noch mal drei tage war
das natürlich extrem teuer so eine woche
ist vergangen und das bauteil ist da
sogar viermal ich habe eigentlich zwei
erstellt haben einfach vier mal
geschickt die ist auch beständig auch
nicht absehen kondensatoren das ist
klasse wie die batterien oder sich die
knie schnell entladen und dadurch auch
die politische super gefährlich sein
können
und den saturn entladen sich nehmen so
schnell dass man sich je nach
kondensator arzt damit richtig richtig
gut schocken kann oder halt sterben da
sind jetzt noch nicht so gefährlich aber
wenn man die fall schlecht dann
explodieren die teile und das kann auch
ins auge gehen darum also ich mir
trotzdem wenn ich damit arbeite auch
wenn es keinen sinn macht eine
schutzbrille tragen ich habe mir ein
kleines schaltplan gemacht worden das
will ich jetzt einmal in die tat
umsetzen und ein problem hauptsache
funktioniert
[Musik]
so über den kondensator diese motoren
gesteckt und erzählt baur auf der motor
will gerne 12 volt so und idee von
kondensator setzt das selbständig das
ding ja ab knips und da kein strom mehr
von der batterie läuft da trotzdem noch
der motor sich eine weile drehen wird
herr gut hat er jetzt nicht gemacht ach
ich hab da was falsch gemacht jetzt hat
er quasi gerade in daten ist jetzt nur
über den kondensator das ist jetzt kann
die batterie und das läuft ja eigentlich
schon recht lang ich stelle jetzt mal
elektromagneten hier an ich weiß ich
auch sehr viel stärker ist jetzt ich
glaube einfach dass der elektro mal
nicht zu wenig strom zieht also muss
jetzt doch noch mal selber einbauen
eine selbst gemachte spiele brauche ich
einen eisenkern und den westen reisen
mantel da dass sie mich wieder so was zu
kriegen halten jetzt überlegt an mit
elektromagneten auszuschlachten dem ich
quasi schon habe und dann einfach auch
zu nutzen leider kann man den nicht so
leicht öffnen und ich glaube das ding
hier vorne das schwarze das ist einmal
kunststoff nicht so leicht zu öffnen
darum brauche ich jetzt einfach mal rein
und
zwar eine kleine variante davon weil das
dabei womöglich kaputtgehen könnte und
jetzt gleich das hier aushebeln man
sieht daneben dass hier einmal eine
andere schule drunter ist die tauschen
jetzt aber aus
[Musik]
ursprünglich als grant extrem messen und
sofort wollte ich mir dafür eigentlich
was intranet druck gemacht jetzt ist mir
aufgefallen ich kann ja auch einfach das
teil der nutzen und schon kann ich jetzt
ne gute spiele wickelt er trat der
darauf hat er war schon extrem dünn der
draht denn ich hab das glaube ich sogar
genauso dünn ich habe hier einen der ist
deutlich dicker aber ich glaube der ist
zudem habe ich noch ein gutes
zwischending dann hab ich jetzt nicht
viel sondern nur hier dreise keine
schulen ich hoffe die reichen so dass
wenn ich jetzt wirklich wunderschön
machen die
ich will noch mit zählen die viele
entwicklungen das denn geben
dann schauen wir uns das mal an sollte
jetzt theoretisch viel mehr power design
profis zumindest der magnet bugsiert
schon mal es sind nur zwei gold kaufen
das ist schon mal recht stark und wenn
ich jetzt hier vor dass es übel strong
das ist richtig stark geil er ist schon
viel stärker tatsächlich wo ja das
kribbelt richtig ich hoffe dass das ding
nicht irgendwie bereits 216 wollt wo das
ist richtig krass aber
es wird schon gut war aber es auch nicht
schlimm sollte auch nur kurz laufen
später das schon mega lustig ich kann
jetzt quasi per knopfdruck das dinge
einmal einschalten und das ding einmal
richtig gas pusten
das ist okay das ist super geil die
kunst ist ja jetzt das ding total nett
[Musik]
ich bin so nah dran und ich weiß dass es
funktioniert aber jetzt kann bautag
kaputt gegangen und ich muss sie neu
bestellen und ich weiß auch nicht wieso
das baut hochgegangen ist es war schade
weil ich wirklich weiß dass es
funktionieren die weitere entwicklung
aber wir an dem jetzigen wissen komme
ich damit einfach nicht weiter jack
gerne linke will beschreibung aus und
habe damit kaum vorbei da geht richtig
ist ein videostudio pcs also pc in
meinem hirn mit dem ich schon seit fast
einem jahr alle möglichen projekte
umsetzt abonniert auf jeden fall mal in
zweikanalton holen da kommt nämlich
sobald ich das perpetuum mobile zum
laufen gebracht hat ein update